you want to see how creepy this gets
hasbro they make toys
hasbro just made a new toy called
the trolls world tour giggle and sing
poppy
this is a doll that that uh you know you
push a butt like all these little toys
right you push a button it makes a sound
so where's the button well it's this
little troll girl
obviously like a child and she's got a
button on her stomach and you push the
button on her stomach and she makes a
sound
she's got another button they put
another button
in between her legs and when you push
that button
she makes she makes disturbing sound the
button itself is disturbingly placed and
the sound she makes are disturbing to
take a listen to one parent who bought
this toy
and discovered this creepy pervy button
so i just touched her tummy and she's
going to sing for a minute
but down here is a button right here on
her privates
and if you push those she makes these
sounds
like a gasping sound
that is yucky
that is yucky and creepy and weird
it's so funny you you hear about all
these conspiracy theories that always
float around the internet of
international pedophile rings and this
pedophile culture right and then
you'll say oh that's like a crazy
conspiracy theory
and and you know no there's no way that
there's this international pedophile
ring that involves heads of state and
prime ministers and members of the royal
family and they go to caribbean island
and say oh wait a second yeah yikes
right and then now forget about that and
it's hard for me to imagine that that
was an accident with that toy doll
i'm not saying there's some some group
somewhere some conspiracy group of like
the illuminati you know who's
making all these kind of weird pedophile
things but it is evidence of a
of a broken sexual culture that
anyone at any point would think that
that is acceptable
to have a little button in on the doll
right there where you push it
and and the doll makes those sounds and
then kids are gonna
get those that is some creepy creepy
stuff
and it it it makes you understand that
this debate we're having right now
on the left and the right it comes down
to a kind of cultural and religious
point we used to just debate over tax
rates that was kind of 80s 90s
conservatism
it's like yeah we're going to lower
taxes a lot more
yeah well if you elect us again we'll
lower taxes even more and i like low
taxes but that's not motivating people
there's a cultural and religious issue
gives you a lot of a lot of respect for
the young kids who are a little bit more
traditional
who are saying something here seriously
broken i hope you enjoyed that short
segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you